Speaker 1: Okay. I think we are getting very
close to being able to sort of close the door
proverbially and maybe at some point a literal
door on my pillow. CEO and founder Mike Lindell,
he actually, quote, testified before the
Louisiana Senate Committee looking at,
I guess, voter fraud at the Voting System
Commission. They were exploring voter fraud.
And he very quickly imploded and tried to cite
some kind of weird data that he has access to,
which proves based on an
investigation of votes that he did
that it's all fraudulent and Trump won or
whatever. And the thing you have to remember is,
does he even have EQ aside from does the data or
do the data show what he claims? Does PILLOW even
have access to such data? And it's not a question
we actually have an answer to. But here's a little
bit of his testimony, for lack of a better term.
Speaker 2: Last thing I would say is our overseas
votes. This is where they were going to. And when
you say computers, you want to know the next era,
emailing and texting in your vote. Right.
You say that could never happen, right?
All of our military votes, almost 97%, were
emailed in from overseas and their families.
All of them that we found so far were for
Biden and that's our overseas military.
Speaker 1: Yeah. So that's a pretty big claim.
Speaker 2: We're doing a class action
lawsuit against all machines. Yeah.
Speaker 1: Okay, so what does he mean by
investigated votes since he doesn't
really have access to that information?
But this is not a new claim.
The claim that he's making is
we've investigated overseas votes and they were
all for Biden, which doesn't make sense. It just
does that you would expect to see some Trump
votes. This has been claimed before. The claim
is specific to Georgia. And it's if you
look at Georgia military overseas ballots,
they were all for Biden and thus it's evidence of
voter fraud. This was widely investigated early
in 2021. This conspiracy theory website called The
Gateway Pundit made a similar claim saying, quote,
In Georgia, a sample. Now, this is a keyword. A
sample of military ballots were reviewed recently
and all went for Joe Biden. There is no way these
were legit. So the first question is, is it true
that all the overseas military ballots in Georgia
were for Biden? And the answer is no. Notice that
the Gateway Pundit uses this phrase a sample
of overseas ballots. This was investigated. And
what they found is that there are some batches of
votes that were all Biden votes. So, for example,
there was a batch of 130 ballots. Those were all
Biden. And there's a reason for that. They had
already been sorted by candidate. So think about
the way that this worked. The ballots come in
massive dumps of ballots as all of you guys know
about. You go, okay, we're going to put the Biden
ballots in one box and we're going to put the
Trump ballots in another box. So you sort them and
you've got a box of all Biden ballots. You hand
that box to someone to review and they go, Hey,
every single one of these is for Biden. It must
be fraud, as they like to say. Well, no, it just
they were correctly sorted. And you're looking at
a Biden box of ballots. So it makes sense that if
they were correctly sorted, that they would all
be Biden, the Georgia secretary of state's office,
did a hand recount of those they were able to,
quote, uphold and reaffirm the original outcome.
There were two other audits done of Georgia's
results, including looking at 15,000 absentee
ballots. There was no evidence of widespread
fraud. If I do an initial sort and it's correct,
and then you review the sort, you would anticipate
that you would have a large tranche of Trump boxes
and. A large tranche of Biden boxes. That's
all that happened here. And the claims are now
starting to be starting that they've
always been absurd, but the claims are now
so transparently toothless, there's nothing there
that my expectation is in the next four months,
particularly as we get closer to the midterms,
that the pillow stuff is going to wind down once
you're beyond the midterms. And even the people
who believe this stuff are starting to think,
you know, Mike, it might not all be just
about to come out in a blockbuster way.
I think you'll see a dramatic reduction in the
amount we hear from pillow. I could be wrong,
but at least that's me optimistically thinking